with all of that said thank you so much
isabella for getting us all started with
building a blog with cordo
isabella is a content strategist data
enthusiast and author with a goal to
drive engagement around all the awesome
things happening at our studio
thank you so much isabella and i will
pull you on stage here with me
thanks for joining us
awesome hello everybody it is so nice to
meet you my name is isabella velasquez i
have the great pleasure of working with
rachel at our studio
and i am
a senior product marketing manager and i
focus on the strategy and the content
creation for the r studio blog
i am almost at my one year mark here at
our studio it's been an amazing time i'm
active in the art community
and sometimes i post on my personal blog
on topics like data cleaning and other
data science things
and i gave a talk on building a blog
with our packages like blog down and
distill a few months ago and i am really
excited to talk about building a blog
with cordo with you today
and so first up i'd love to hear from
you do you have any technical blogs or
data science blogs that you love to read
and please put them in the chat and
share why
so to get started i'm actually going to
do something a little different today in
that i don't have slides
and so i have everything available as a
court of blog and we'll be going through
content this way
and one reason i wanted to try this out
was to showcase the really cool things
that authoring and cordo can do
and so all of the code is available on
github if you see something and you'd
like to replicate it on your own quarto
blog
and so for today's agenda we're going to
be going through
possible reasons for creating a blog a
recap of cordo which is an open source
scientific and technical publishing
system built on pandoc
how to create a website in cordo and
then more specifically how to build a
quartal blog and write posts
and so we do have some assumptions for
today first is that you know a bit of r
in our markdown
second is that you know about cordo and
just need a bit of a refresher
so i won't be covering everything in
full detail today but if you find
yourself wanting to start from the
beginning you can watch tom walks
webinar from a few weeks ago called
welcome to cordo to catch up
and finally we assume that you're
interested in using the ide for our our
studio desktop
so we'll be
using our studio for this talk
and running the commands in the ide
on the cordo website there are
step-by-step instructions if you use vs
code or jupyter lab as well as anything
you may need for running the command
line instead of rstudio
and so for how today will work
you have a few options so this website
is available at rstd dot io slash build
dash quarto dash blog
and you can click the github icon up
here and
if you'd like to see the source code
if you'd like to follow along the
exercises i have you can clone the
github repository available at rstd dot
io slash quarto dash blog exercise dash
refill
and you can follow along in the example
blog that i've created for you
you can also work off the rstudio
project available at rstd.io
cordo dash blog exercise cloud and uh
the advantage of our studio cloud is you
don't have to install our studio on your
computer everything can be done in your
browser
you could also
create a whole new quartal blog on your
computer and which we will cover in
a few minutes but it won't have the
notes that i included and you have to
make sure that you have the latest
version of our markdown installed
so no i won't be stopping for the
exercises very long so another way that
you can participate is just follow uh
and listen to my soothing voice and the
recording will be available on youtube
immediately after this presentation and
the github repositories and our studio
cloud project will remain up and
available to you as well
and another thing is along across the
site i'll have links to the quarto
website's documentations relevant page
so the quarto documentation is excellent
i honestly recommend reading every page
and so we're just going to cover the
basics of creating a blog but say you
have a question like how do i write this
how do i do this
please check the documentation first
yes
awesome
so before we dive into
uh using porto you may be wondering why
should i build a blog in the first place
so while the title of the talk is
building a blog with quoto porto there's
uh
let's talk generally about different
types of websites so blogs are a certain
type of website that usually have a
chronological order and they can be
indexed and syndicated on rss feeds and
while some website pages are static and
not updated very frequently a blog is
dynamic and usually updated pretty often
there are other forms of websites that
form support dialogue and form libraries
of knowledge like forums and wikis and
uh but blogs specifically add time as a
factor to consider as they will only be
successful with continuous engagement
and creation
and the type of content is different too
so more real-time events and so
while we're talking about quartal blogs
today just know cordo actually supports
other types of websites as well
and so we should also talk about uh why
build a blog and so i'd like to share
some insights i've gleaned from really
amazing talks by david robinson miles
salmon
rebecca barter allison hill and many
others on this topic and i have a link
to a youtube playlist on the website for
you as well
so you may have heard david robinson's
advice that if you've shared something
three times it's time to write a blog
about it and so in terms of the skills
needed for data science a blog can help
showcase collaboration and communication
a blog perform provides a platform to
share the things you've learned like any
cool packages you've tried or created
how-tos other processes and write about
your opinions give updates and so much
more
another thing about blogs is uh they
provide a platform
to practice writing for someone other
than yourself
and they can form a sort of portfolio
that makes it easy to share
and since it's all in one place it
allows for centralization of your work
rather than having it in different spots
and so here are some examples of
existing quarto blogs and we can learn
about these writers and the awesome
stuff that they're doing and we not only
that they also share their knowledge in
that they also share their code and
looking at other people's code is a
wonderful way of learning and i really
highly recommend doing that when you're
creating your own quarter blog i know i
did
and so usually we talk about reasons to
create a personal blog especially if
you're looking for a job say but i also
want to note your team or organization
could benefit from having a blog as well
so external blogs like the ones we have
at our studio are examples we keep the
community up to date with events and
product updates we share stories and
from others who use our tools to show
what's possible with them in a variety
of contexts
and internal blogs and organizations can
help you share information between team
members in an easy and efficient way
so have you ever tried to find some
advice that your colleague sent to you
via email it can be really hard to find
and so with a blog key information can
be
searchable and in one place speeding up
communication folks can search for
information from the past while easily
seeing what's the newest info it also
gives your colleagues an opportunity to
collaborate and share thoughts very
quickly rather than having them siloed
in conversations or an email and ideally
if foster is a community that's open and
inclusive and shows that you care about
each other's work and opinions
and so in terms of the sorts of posts
that you can consider for your blog
let's say we want to create a blog for
an internal data science community
topics can include the reflections on
projects that just happened how things
went lessons learned where to find
outputs
and besides the type of pose you also
want to consider the content of the post
that you create so it's about finding a
sweet spot between
length media like text images and photos
and other formats that resonate with
your audience and so here's an example
of using a blog listing page to showcase
various talks and presentations
and so
when considering building a blog ask
yourself why do you want to create a
blog and having a clear goal can help
you develop your blog and explain it's
the its purpose to others
and then what are the values you want to
instill in your blog that's meant to be
a place for inclusivity and openness and
motivation you want to make sure that
your blog demonstrates those values
and then what is valuable and relevant
content so key to the success is knowing
what others would find valuable and
relevant and making sure that that is
what is put on the blog
and
also you don't want your blog to be a
big imposition or write into but
maintain
if it's something that's easily done or
even fun then it's a lot easier
and there's a technical aspect of
building a blog hopefully you can build
the skills and the infrastructure that
you need to keep your blog going and
with that we can get to the technical
part
so let's start off by saying
what is quarto
as i mentioned earlier you may have
joined tom locke's webinar from a few
weeks ago called welcome to cordo if you
did not join i highly recommend watching
the recording on youtube tom does a
spectacular job introducing quarto and
how to author documents he's been a
major help in putting this presentation
together so thank you so much tom
i'm going to do a high level uh recap of
some of the points mentioned in the
webinar that are crucial for explaining
how to build a blog with cordo
so first up what is it it's an open
source scientific and technical
publishing system
in terms of how it works while our
markdown
needs are to run porto is a command line
interface that does not need any
programming language quarto renders
plain text like markdown files and mixed
formats like jupyter notebooks into
static pdfs or word documents or html
pages reports and like we'll see today
websites
and so cordo is not language specific
meaning you don't have to have any
particular programming language to run
it
so for those of you who use our markdown
it lets you go beyond
r and knit r and use other languages
like julia or python natively
so cordo also allows you to have
client-side interactivity which means
that you can run shiny apps directly in
the browser
and cordo also has built-in native
javascripts like html and
observable js
so here's an example of a
shiny
app within a recorded document you can
see it changes just within the browser
the portal is also not tied to any one
integrated development environment
authors can use rstudio vs code etc and
different members working on the same
quarto project can use different tools
to write their documents rather than
having to conform to a specific one
essentially cordo lets you mix and merge
and interact across languages so it's a
very big deal for folks in
all different communities
if you want to see everything that cordo
can do you can run
quarto
help in the terminal
discussions and bug reports can go on
github and there are a lot of friendly
folks on twitter and the r studio
community where you can go to the quarto
tag and ask questions and as well as in
faq as well
so now that you know what quarto is
let's discuss why
you may want to use it to build a blog
so if your work is technical in nature
it's helpful to use the same tools for
writing your in your blog you're going
to write about data analysis then it
makes sense to use a tool that lets you
see and run the code
so in my early days of blogging i used a
popular platform and anytime i'd write
our code i'd have to change the little
lesson sign to um
manually each and every time and so
things were not reproducible yeah for
the readers which is not good if you're
trying to write say a tutorial
so it was a big name
and so writing with cordo means that you
can do all the nifty things that you
usually can do
like have syntax highlighting and
executable code while you're writing the
text
and you know when you run it you'll get
the same output as before
and there's also other things that make
it easier like integrating with github
having full control of your page all
static files no databases or logins
so one question you may have
especially if you're an our markdown
user is whether you need to use cordo to
create a blog
and the answer is no
the our markdown and the down family are
not going away so the block down and
distill packages are still excellent
options for you
and so if you like using our markdown
there's no reason to switch
uh our markdown will continue to be
supported and work as always has been
the switch is not impacted
but if you're on a multilingual team or
primarily a python user or want to use
the features available in cordo then you
may consider trying it out
all right now let's talk about cordo and
rstudio
so as i mentioned earlier we're going to
focus on cordo in the r studio ide
porto is now included with our studio
version 2022
0.07.1 and above
so what that means is that you there's
no need for a separate download or
installation if you have the latest
version of our studio so if you'd like
to follow along with the exercises
please make sure that you have this
version ready to go
and so cordo has a but sorry our studio
has a bunch of features that make
technical authoring easier so one of
those these is the visual editor mode so
if you write markdown code it will run
their changes in real time
and the visual editor mode includes
extensive support for cordo like adding
tables and images and citations all
sorts of things and so
here
is an example
we create a heading and see it
immediately
we can type it out
from here we can go to the editor
toolbar and insert a table
add a caption if necessary
and then i have render on save on so i
can preview my site and see what it will
look like
so the table is down here
and so say i want to change from column
one to column a
i can change that and then save
and then the preview will update so i
can see what exactly it will look like
and there's more documentation as well
in addition the ide has a nifty outline
feature that makes it easy to scroll
through your document so
here is an example
uh the outline is there on the right and
clicking on the different headings takes
us to that part of the page immediately
and one last thing i wanted to mention
is yeah the yaml intelligence so yaml
stands for yet another markup language
it's the metadata of your document and
it's included at the top
so what it does is it uses key value
pairs to denote what options you'd like
to specify in the desired choice
and yamaha also has options to control
more about our document as well so it's
very particular
you have to be very careful about the
characters that you use the spacing that
you're using so just take a note of that
if you've ever run a document and
encounter an error
make sure your yaml is correct
and so in the our studio visual editor
yaml completion is available for project
files front matter and executable code
options so that means when you type yaml
and press tab it will give you a list of
the options to complete your yaml field
this is both for the option name and the
option selection
and so here is an example
i start typing what i want i see the
list that is available
scroll to the one i want and then i also
see a list for the possible options
and to note the ide will also highlight
if you have incorrect yaml so highlight
the error and um
when the documents are saved you can see
the little red x
okay with that quick intro to our studio
and porta
now let's get started building a blog
all right let's build a blog with cordo
so project directories are recorded
projects i'm sorry are directories they
provide a way to render all or some of
the directory files with a single
command they share yaml configuration
across multiple documents
they have the ability to redirect
artifacts to another directory and also
you can freeze outputs which we will
talk about in more detail later
so one type of quarto project is a
portal website and so this is convenient
way to publish a group of documents and
documents that are published as part of
a website share navigational elements
rendering options and visual style and
they can be published to a variety of
destinations so quarter websites books
and blogs are very similar in that they
associate these multiple pages and
resources into a connected resource and
so like we talked about earlier there
are specific things that make a blog
blog and so a quartal blog is a quarter
website with specific opinions already
made and it includes a listing created
from a directory and we can customize
those listings in various ways
so let's get started
uh like with everything else you could
use the command line to create the blog
alternatively we're going to use the
rstudio ide
by going to file new directory giving
the directory a name and opening up the
project and this will create the
scaffolding for a simple blog
so here is a video
go to file
new project
new directory
order blog
give it a name
my new blog
and create project
there on the bottom right you can see
the scaffolding that has been created
so there is a workflow that you should
use to view your site you could again
use the command line interface or you
could use our studios build tab to
render and preview a website
so my recommendation is to first preview
the website and
make sure that render is save is on so
every time that you save a file you can
see what changes have been made in your
viewer or in your browser
so here is an example of
clicking render on save and previewing
the site
when anytime i type something and save i
can see the changes in the viewer
here's render and save
vp website
i'm going to add some text on this page
at the top
when i save i can see test test showing
up there on my website now
so note if you make changes to the
global options you'll need to fully
re-render your site to have all of the
changes reflected and you should always
fully render your site before you deploy
it to your publishing platform even if
you've already previewed the changes to
some on some of your pages in this
viewer
all right
if you want to try out the exercises you
can now either create a whole new blog
in our studio
clone github repository or open the
rstudio cloud project and so like i said
i won't be
leaving too much time to go through this
but i will do it on my own screen if
you'd rather just watch
so i have the rc20 cloud project here
and i was doing the project
isabella do you want to ask any
questions oh yes of course okay some
there's a few questions that are coming
in
right now and
one was um
from scout is it possible to add a blog
to a project that began as a quarter
website
yes that's right um you can and so
if you start off as a
portal website essentially what defines
a blog is having this listing page
that we will talk about later and so you
can create the listing page um by adding
it as a portal file later on if you
decide that you'd rather you'd like to
have a blog so yes
awesome thank you
um and somebody else had asked what is
the blog that you're using in the
presentation so i just wanted to show
that here on the screen again as well
sure should i switch back to it nope no
i just i put it up
as like a caption
but um i'll i'll keep some of the other
questions until after you you go through
this as well thank you yeah for sure so
um we're going to be talking about
styling your blog a little bit later in
terms of the theme i'm using it's the
litera theme and then i did some custom
html in order to make the fonts and the
um and the colors look the way that i'd
like and so
if you look at the source code of the
website on github you can see you know
what exactly does the css look like
as well as the website configuration
page which we will talk about in a
little bit
and um
and yeah there's like a lot of different
ways of customizing your website to make
it look you know exactly how you would
like
cool
and so
here in the r studio cloud project um
for this first exercise it is previewing
the website
just to have it ready to go
for whenever we make changes with the
exercises later on and so previewing the
website gives you the
the view that um that you're interested
in
all right
it sounded like you were underwater for
a second i think maybe
about that
okay i'm just
trying to find my place and then i'll be
right back
okay
awesome
so
uh when you create a blog to our studio
you'll see some automatically created
files in the project like i mentioned in
the
bottom right
and so let's go through each of these
so first up we're going to talk about
qmd
file
this is your home direct which will be
the landing page for your site so when
somebody goes to
www.yoursite.com this is the first thing
that they will see
and so
in this default blog it is a special
type of document called a listing page
that lists all the other documents so
when creating a new blog the listing
page or the landing page will default to
this listing page for the documents in
that post directory
that is it will default to your blog and
so there are ways to customize like say
you rather have the about page as your
landing page um whatever is your
index.qmd file in your home directory
will be your landing page so you could
change that to index.qmd and change
your current q index.qmd to something
else and i've listed a blog post on how
to do this under the resources of this
website
and so this is the yaml in your default
index.qmd file so it helps configure
that document so let's talk through each
line
so in title title is the title of your
listing
listing generates the contents of a page
or region of a page from a set of portal
documents and other custom data
and so this is essentially what makes up
a blog
contents control
what
documents are included in the listing by
specifying a list of input files
so in the default blog
the listing includes all the quarto
documents in the post directory or
all the i'm sorry all the documents in
the post directory
sort controls the order of the listing
so by default it is uh will be ordered
by their date
you can also change it to title
um
you can also change it by title instead
change it to ascending by using asc
here's by title
and you can also sort it by more than
one attribute like so
type controls how the listings look
there are three built-in types of
listing that you can choose from so
there's grid
there's table
or there's default
and
you can also create custom listings by
using embedded javascript templating so
or ejs so ejs is a templating language
that lets you generate html markup uh
with plain javascript and so just to to
my own horn this is what my own personal
website looks like and so
you can control things like the
placement the size and all sorts of
styling for your listing if you would
like with ejs
and so with categories you can add a
list of categories to the listing page
you can see them here on the right and
so when a users click a category the
page will be updated to only include the
listing items that match that selected
category so you can
also choose from a few different
displays so by default it is numbered
you can also choose unnumbered
or cloud
the sort ui
will give users a selection box to
choose how to sort the items in the
listing
by default
the sorting control allows the user to
control by title date or author and you
can also control which fields are
included by providing a list under sort
ui or you can also just turn this off by
setting it to false
and filter ui is similar it provides a
filter box a position at the top right
of the listing content and the filter
box allows readers to perform a search
of the listing contents and you can also
disable this option
page layout controls the layout used for
the page by default quartal documents
display content centered or at a width
that's optimized for readability but if
you want to use other layouts you can
customize it here
and then there's title block banner
which positions a formatted title block
at the top of the page and so we'll talk
a little bit more about this later
so now let's go back to our exercise so
in the index.qmv file of your quarto
blog
change the title of your listing page
add another listing type change sort to
date ascending
and see what happens when you change
filter to true
so
if you open up
say your project
the index.qmd file is here in your home
directory yeah i won't say in case
you're trying to do this on your own
and
i've also included the instructions down
here
another listing type
and that's the truth
so
if you tried it out you should be seeing
a new title a new listing type
of filtering
and also a different way of organizing
the blog posts
cool
so now let's move on to another file
that's automatically created the about
qmd file
so the about qmd file is a special
template that's designed to present a
person or organization it'll be
automatically included or added when you
build a blog
and so please see the yaml here on the
right
uh let's walk through each line of the
yaml
so again title will be the title of your
about page
image will be the image for the about
page
uh about tells us to use the special
template that looks the way that you can
see
there and then template controls uh more
specifically how the about page looks
and so there are five built-in templates
you can use and there's hoya trailers
[Music]
and broadside
continuing on in the yaml
links share a set of links to other
resources so you can add urls and text
and icons
and so
there is a note by default the about
page
will be rendered using the entire
documents of the page you could also
choose to only use a portion of the page
to populate the template and there's
more about that in the quarter
documentation
all right so let's go back to our
exercise
in the about qmd page of your blog edit
the title of your page
change the template to marquee and
update the links to your own profile
pages
this
so if you have done that and go back to
your preview
you should see the updated and from um
updated about page now
okay
so the next file we're going to dig into
is the underscore quarto.yaml file so
this is the configuration file for your
website and here's what the
yaml looks like so let's walk through
each line together
project is the type of the project so
um whereas a blog is a specific type of
quarto website you could also do a book
or other sorts of projects
and uh the configuration
title is the title of your blog
and then there is the navigation bar so
this is the top navigation bar that you
can see
and
write specifies to
write this in the right side of the top
navigation bar you could also do left
and then the following three are the
files to
be um
to be linked
so these can be pages inside and outside
of your website
and just a note there's also a sidebar
and hybrid navigation if you want to
check those out in the in the um
in the quarter documentation
so like let's try this out
so in the
underscorecordo.yaml file of your quarto
blog
oh
i apologize i missed this um
i forgot to mention so the features and
functionality are very extensive and you
have a lot of options for customizing
your site so for example you can change
the color of your navigation bar by
adding background and then a color
underneath
and there are also options for the
individual navigation items so while up
top the default blog has links that uh
to share here we are just sharing some
text
like
so right now let's try it out uh in your
project open up the cordo.yaml file uh
change the background to a different
color add another hyperlink and then add
your name to the left side of the top
navigation bar
and she
background
i did refer to my own stuff
so one thing to note is uh again spacing
is very very important in yaml so make
sure that you're lining up things uh
accurately
saving that
gives us this new configuration in my
case i made it a red banner i called it
new site
so the next section of the quarto uh
unders
the next section of the quarter yamo
file adds your theme so blogs can use
any of the 25 bootswatch scenes that are
included with cordo you can also create
your own themes and so the default blog
uses the cosmo theme and the quarter
websites will also uh also
let you do a dark and light theme but
we'll get to that in a sec so here's an
example of some of the bootswatch themes
cosmo the default
you can change it to darkly by
specifying theme darkly
or another one called sketchy and i've
included a list of the 25 over here
and so
um
if you
specify a dark theme a toggle will allow
your readers to switch between light and
dark and so you specify it in your
quarto.yaml file by adding light and
dark underneath theme and then the
themes that you would like
and here's an example of the toggle up
top
and it just
moves back and forth
and another thing that if you'd like to
customize is you can change the syntax
highlighting or the color of the fonts
of your
of your code chunks and so
you can run a command line interface to
see all of the options or use yaml
intelligence to see all the options as
well
and so here's an example of the espresso
highlight theme or highlight style so
you
denote it this way
here's what eiffel looks like
or zenburn
and so if you like uh you can try it out
uh change up your theme on your chordo
blog
add a dark theme with another bootswatch
theme and then change the syntax
highlighting to espresso
so go to that yaml file
i'm going to change this to
let's say montero which is the one i'm
using for my current
here is the syntax for light and dark
and then finally syntax highlighting is
by using highlight style
here's the animal intelligence
and now we can see the new theme has
been added i don't have any code right
now but if if i did how could you be
able to see it i should have edited
apologies
and so last thing uh that's on that
quarto.yaml file is the styles.css file
so this is the css style sheet so csl
style style sheets um stylized elements
written in markup language and so you
can change things like what your
headings look like so the default blog
comes with a file called styles.css
and you could also use a sas file
instead of css so sas stands for as
syntactically awesome style sheets and
it's a great way of modularizing your
css and generally making styling a bit
easier so
let's change the title or sorry the font
of our headings so you can
in your styles.css file add this command
um or these the script and then it will
change the font in your um
in your blog
so
here
if you have
i'm just going to copy and paste okay
faster
save it
this might be one of those global
configurations that you need to
rerun there we go
like i mentioned earlier some things
will show in the preview and some things
you'll need to fully re-render your site
in this case we were able to see our
new font after we re-rendered
all right congratulations we built a
vlog with porta
and so now that we have our listing and
our page looking the way that we'd like
we can write a blog post
so let's create a new post
so posts are saved in an indiv
in an individual folder oh sorry posts
are saved in a folder
here you can find it post
and then each post
is an individual folder
within
a document saved inside
like so
and by default in the default blog
the
posts that make up the contents of the
blog are located in the post directory
and you can add a new post
by creating a subfolder within the post
folder
and then adding an index.qmd file inside
that subfolder
and you can create these manually or as
usual you could also
do it through rstudio whatever works
best for you so this is what it would
look like within rstudio you could do a
new folder
give it a post name
and then index.
create an index.qmd file by new blank
file
and then providing it there
so that qmd file is a new blog post so
when you render the document the home
page will automatically update to
include the new post at the top of the
listing
and the folder name will be the slug or
the part of the url that identifies the
page and the name of the qmd file will
be the latter part of the slug so if you
want your post to have the names of your
folder you would just call the post
index.commv
so
additionally you can also
add a metadata.yaml file to the post
folder and that should create shared
metadata with all the files in the
folder
so while the quarto yaml file sets a
configuration for the entire website
this is only to the post within that
post directory
so if you open up the meta
metadata.yaml file when you create a new
blog project you'll see this freeze uh
set to true
so when a post is rendered with freeze
is set to true the markdown output from
the underlying engine like jupiter or
nidar is saved and so when the entire
site is rendered those computations will
not be rerun but read from uh previously
frozen
results
so essentially if set to true freeze
means only rerun when i explicitly say
so
and this can save a lot of time when
you're trying to rerun all the documents
in your website
and as mentioned earlier there's also
title block banner which creates a
banner style
title block for all the posts in the
listing and so this can be a color
it can also be an image
so let's try this out in our own
blog and change the title
uh color banner banner to color to
something else and then go check out one
of your posts
so within the post file or folder
there's the metadata yellow
and let's just change it to this color
oh i closed my preview
so clicking on a post gives us that new
banner color
and so
uh one other thing to note
one thing
sorry so now let's go into a file uh
within a post folder again you'll see
the yaml setup at the top of the
document
let's go through each line title is the
title of the post
author is the author of the post or you
can also have multiple authors
you can list them with a list or like so
there's two different ways
date is the date of the post
uh posts for the future will still show
up on your site please note and
categories are the categories that you
have set up for your posts so if
categories are set to true in the quarto
yaml configuration file from before
you'll see these categories show up on
your listing page and like authors
there's a few different ways if you'd
like to write multiple categories for a
single post
and you note that you can also set your
post as draft to true
so that your post doesn't show up even
if you
have deployed your site
so let's create a new post called my
first post
and and then create um the yellow for
the file
so we could do that
in the post
new folder
i'm going to switch this source really
fast just so you can see what this would
look like
and
my
post
you could set it up this way if you'd
like
sorry about that
and here's my new post in the listing
page
all right so with that uh below the yaml
that you just created you would actually
write your post so let's see how to
author some posts
rachel any questions so far i know that
um
yeah lots of
questions yeah definitely thank you
go over to let's see we'll ask one from
linkedin
i see deepsea just asked she said this
is great isabella how did you add the
videos with play buttons and also the
rstudio snippet where you live wrote the
code and ran it on the fly
within the blog
is that
as an aspect of rstudio connect or is
that a chordo
functionality i see so the the videos
that i'm playing i'm actually that's
actually not either that's a video psych
um called wistia that lets you embed
videos uh so not
it's
then badge uh file or sorry link is
through html and then i just
you can embed any html that you'd like
into a quarter document and so that's
how i have embedded the videos
awesome thank you
another question from earlier was
um so does quartal work with hugo and
blog down
yeah so you can actually add hugo to
your quarter website and there is
documentation on the
on the cordo website and documentation
website portal.org
and i have to admit i haven't tried it
myself when i switched over to cordo i
just stopped using hugo it came from
block down
so definitely check out that out and i
do have um
as a section on my grading from our
markdown that uh i'll try to make sure
that we get to
okay awesome um i'll ask two more
questions here and then i'll send it
back to you with a presentation yeah but
santiago had asked on linkedin
is it possible to host the blog
somewhere other than cordopub
yes um i'm actually going to go ahead
and skip the literate programming in
quarto just because um
tom does a fantastic job uh covering
this in his previous webinar and if
you're familiar with our markdown it
essentially just goes through how to
build things et cetera and so um we'll
talk about publishing your blog
in um next
okay awesome
um okay let me just do over to one more
thank you
the slido where just a reminder you can
ask anonymous questions over on slido as
well
um
and somebody had asked
can you put a bunch of
files in the
um posts folder and have it render in a
listings page
yeah um there are different ways of
adding
uh non
like documents that you didn't create
through quarto to cordo um if you go to
the court of documentation and look up
resources it shows you how to do exactly
that
and actually the
um
the example that i showed from sylvia
at the beginning
she had created a listing page with her
talks and none of the talks were
actually hosted on the cordo and she was
still able to create a listing page um
i
i recommend like looking at that that's
under introduction uh why
create a blog
awesome and the first one that you said
was in the documentation is that the
document listings
section
i was just trying to find the link to
share we could share them after that
okay
awesome i'll send it back over to you
and then we'll see some other questions
for after too
yeah thank you
awesome
so yes uh
actually i'll just show this really fast
so you know what exactly is here but
like i mentioned um this will just cover
some markdown basics
uh fence divs are amazing again if
you've never seen these before i really
really recommend just checking all the
different options that you have of the
things that you've seen like those
column notes or the tab sets uh
throughout this website or through these
fence divs and they're super cool
uh i also know a little bit on using
julia and and other programming
languages within cordo
and how to render the documents which is
very similar to what we have been seeing
with rendering the website so if you are
interested please check out the section
with the cute cat with glasses
and in terms of publishing your blog yes
you can publish cordo in a variety of
ways
i chose quarto pub which is a free
service and uh that you can sign up for
that's very nice for
hobby projects things that you don't
mind being public and things like that
in addition you can also use things like
github pages our studio connect netlify
all these other sorts of platforms that
let you
uh go
like
you know customize your website in the
way that you'd like so if you'd like to
use continuous integration so that every
time you know you change your site you
know how to render things like that you
can configure these
platforms as you wish arterial connect
is a great option if you're within your
organization and you want your blog to
be private and shared among your team
members netlify also has options if you
have um a bigger website that you want
to host or you want to add password
protection and things like that
and so
in this
case i used quarto pub
it was actually my first project on
cordova so that was pretty exciting
like i mentioned you have to know uh
that it's publicly visible that it has a
size limitation but generally a really
great option for um for hosting your
website
and so i won't go through like how to do
this uh just on account of time but
uh
if you would like to publish the quarto
pub on your local computer you can do so
after you set up an account and running
quarto publish and it will literally
like walk you through every single step
that you need in order to publish your
site
and then your site will be online like
this one is
and one a quick thing to know if you'd
like to publish your blog say the one
that you're creating on our studio cloud
it is slightly different in terms of the
steps involved um but it's not um
too many more steps you just have to
manually give your uh our studio cloud
account your access token as opposed to
using the the built-in quarto publish
ability of like opening up the
authentication in a new page so just
wanted to know
and for some other things in terms of
migrating from our markdown uh this
isn't specific to hugo just in general
if you're interested in our markdown if
you have a bunch of our markdown posts
and you'd like to move them over to our
quarto
blog it's just some things to note this
is actually the process that i went
through migrating from block down to
cordo so cordo can render any existing
arm markdown document without uh really
changing too much and if you change uh
rmd on the file name to dot qmd it
forces it into a quartal document and so
uh that is essentially what i did i just
took on my post folder and i pasted it
over to my new uh my new
project and my new coordinate project
and so if you do run into any errors
just go into the file and see what
occurred so one thing that i ran into is
the yaml categories in my old blog were
different than they were in quarto
so for example like summary is now
description so i had to go through and
manually change all of that in the yaml
um in order for it to run but if you
look at the source code they're actually
all still rmd files i didn't change
anything within the text itself um just
had to change the yaml
and so uh one other thing to note is uh
quarto uses a different
styling for the code chunk options so
whereas before they would be listed in
on the first line of a code uh chunk now
you can add them within the code chunk
itself using this uh very handy hash
pipe comment and so like so
and
one thing to note though
uh you can still use the old way of
doing it but we recommend switching over
as it will help with compatibility in
the future
and so
in the newest version of netara which
actually
very recently came out there's actually
a function called convert chunk header
that you can use and it will help you
convert all your old in header chunk
options to the new and body uh chunk
options and so
this is what it looks like you would
give it the file to convert and then the
file
the output file that you would like and
it doesn't have to be a quarter document
it can also be an our markdown document
and thank you all so much i really
appreciate uh
being able to build a blog with you i
added there's so many fantastic
resources both official quarto
documentation and just amazing examples
tutorials and um features from the
community so
like so many of the things that you saw
today were contributed by members of the
community cordo has extensions that lets
you modify the behavior of porto so
those things like being able to click on
a picture and having it zoom is a
quarter extension that you can install
um in addition there are specific things
that you may like to add to your blog
like rss feeds and subscriptions and and
there's detailed documentation on how to
do that as well
and
like i mentioned before
if you are interested in migrating you
may want to add redirects to your slugs
and so uh then
navarro like wrote an awesome post on
how to do that as well as uh more
information on continuous integration so
really like uh check out the quartopub
hashtag on twitter
follow along on github and just really
check out all the really amazing things
that are happening around corda so thank
you
awesome thank you so much isabella that
was great
i see a lot of you can't see this right
now but a lot of people in the chat
right now just saying
awesome overview thank you so much
isabella
um
there are a lot of questions here so
we'll make sure that we
get to them as well but also so everyone
knows isabella runs the rstudio blog so
i am sure that we will get some of these
questions covered in a blog post too
um but let me go over to
some of the other questions
um and if you want to stop your screen
share you can see them as i pull them up
too here i'll pull it over
okay
one of the questions earlier was
what does cordo offer over blog down
yeah so it really is what tool you would
like to use so block down specifically
uses hugo as well as arm markdown and
hugo allows folks to really heavily like
customize their their blog exactly the
way that they would like perhaps it's
just you know a tool that they prefer
and so if um
you know if that is your preference then
there is again no reason to switch over
from block down as specifically like
what does quarto offer over a block down
is those sorts of chordo features like
um being able to uh use
other languages like python and julia
natively
being able to use the other features
that are being developed in cordo and uh
um so again it's just like what is the
right tool for your blogging platform
and then deciding and going with that
great thank you
i know you just briefly covered the
extensions at the end but um eugene had
asked do you use any quarter extensions
yes and so
if
maybe i can share my screen let me find
it really fast
can you see me my screen all right yes
yeah awesome so this in particular is
called a light box
uh this ability to click into a photo
scroll through them have it like kind of
pop up and have a back dac background so
that you can focus on it i've linked to
it here it's called quarter light box
in terms of installation you run
something on the command line add the
feature to your yaml and then you're
ready to go
another one uh that was posted pretty
recently
is uh this portal nutshell extension and
so i didn't go too deep into this but
say you have um
information that you want some folks to
click on and some don't and so or some
not to this extension lets you do this
little like drop down of more
information if you click on this link
and so a very handy little extension and
so
um yeah there are lots of things that
are being developed and so
another extension that i linked to and
the resources is being able to use short
codes for
uh for twitter and for youtube rather
than having to embed the html so lots
and lots of uh different extensions
available
cool thank you
um another question i think this maybe
came over from linkedin
um but corey asks so the posts don't
have to follow the standard
uh year month date format like in
distill
no there are ways of customizing it and
you probably know what i'm going to say
it's it's in the corner documentation
all right yeah and we can try and find
these specific links to this yeah which
is a
document too
yeah another way of sorry the
ejs templating that i mentioned that
lets you like control how to customize
your your listing um is another way of
controlling what the date looks like too
okay cool
um i see also jeff asked
how do you navigate through your quarto
blog through the browser it seems it
doesn't seem like you're clicking
anything
oh
i was actually clicking on something
that i didn't
know um
let's see
lots of great questions thank you
everybody
somebody asked anonymously how can i
render
my qmd files inside github
oh i have to i don't know um you have to
follow up on that
okay
great let me
see sorry i'm collecting things from all
over the place
on youtube linkedin or
a slido so let me jump back over to
youtube
ken
um somebody had asked
um finai or can we have the same qmd
file for a blog and a book
this
i am not sure uh if i had to guess i
would say
that you would need to have separate
projects and perhaps you can link across
projects
and
that this i would also have to double
check
and i know you just touched upon ejs and
i might need to be reminded of exactly
what that means but
jason asks would ejs be the way to add a
new listing option such as location
yeah that's right and there's um other
ways of adding like different fields you
know if you are interested uh as well
okay and could you explain ejs again for
me sorry yeah of course uh
so it is a template that lets you use um
html
for
oh sorry i had it like written down but
it it it essentially lets you use um
uh html to create javascript templates
so okay yeah great thank you
of course
okay we'll take um a few more questions
here one fun one is
great presentation isabella did you draw
the cats
i'm not i would have loved to draw the
kitty cats for you they are both from
the uh
the ai
generator called dolly and so i would do
things like uh illustration of cat
playing with printing press and then
also raw pixel pixels which provides
public domain um
illustrations and images as well
i'll have to play around with that
i see
i didn't copy this over into text oh
here it is somebody had asked
anonymously
the challenge for our markdown migration
is that the code or data from old posts
is stale
what do you do then
um
and they mentioned using freeze going
forward
yeah and that's very very very true uh
so there are some blog posts out there
that
that share a workflow for making your
blog post reproducible like from our
markdown and there are things like using
rf and to record things like the package
version um
and
you know you could get even uh more by
using docker to like
specify the operating system and things
like that and so yeah it it's very much
the case that uh freeze will definitely
help in terms of you know if you're
using a quartal block moving forward uh
but if you know if you have a blog post
then um it's using an old version of a
package that and the function no longer
works that you may have to just like
update the yeah it would say like you
either have to update your code or if
you have like the html um rendering of
that our markdown file you can port that
over to cordo instead and try to like
mitigate you know all the manual work
that you're going to have to do
thank you i see a question here that
might actually be for me
but what's victor asks when is the next
meet up so
we have meetups like this every tuesday
at 12 eastern time so the same time as
the one today
and then we also have a data science
hangout
every thursday and so those are a little
bit different but
they hang
every thursday is not a presentation
it's just an informal time for the
community to
join and ask questions to a different
data science leader each week
um so tiger tang
is um from carfax is joining us this
thursday if you want to join us at that
and if you want to join the next meetup
next week
we have a talk on
collecting and acting on employee
engagement data
at the veterans affairs
and using shiny so that will be a great
talk as well i'm going to share
on the screen right here just where the
calendar
of those events is too
and that's actually the first quarter
document that i ever made
uh let's see okay i'm gonna ask just a
few more questions is that okay okay
i see arun asked
can we use custom icons for the about
qmd
similar to postcards
yeah so oh i forgot to mention this is
also an extension um there is a font
awesome extension that lets you use font
awesome icons and actually the the
github icons that you see throughout the
website are
from that extension
and so yes i i recommend
looking at extension
great and i see
abu
bakar you asked
you said publishing to quartopub is free
please explain more i was going to share
the link to cordopub
in the chat as well but isabella if you
have anything else to add
you want to jump in
yeah it's it's exactly that you can um
sign up you'll have an account and when
you press or type cordo publish on your
blog it will ask you to authenticate so
if you're already logged into your
browser you log into your browser when
you come back to your
say our studio id then it will let you
publish it directly there
like i mentioned there are a few
limitations i think it said like 100
gigabytes for the
site and um
and a soft limit as well and another
thing to note it's
your documents will be publicly
available so you have to make sure there
are things that you're okay sharing um
with other people and but yeah
completely free
thank you
another great question on slido from
mary
does cordo have any built-in
accessibility tools or a checker to be
sure the blog meets accessibility
requirements
yes there are a ton of accessibility
features and during the development
process this was a like
like consistently part of like you know
how what do we add how do we add it like
how can we make sure it's available um
of course the quarter documentation goes
into it one example is in the
um say the top navigation toolbar if you
want to add accessible links to that
title href icon or whatnot um you can do
so
if you check out
uh
a quarter tip a day
and
and i have linked that in the resources
as well as well if you go there um
there are actually several posts there
on specific accessibility features that
you can use in porto
awesome thank you so much isabella i
think we got
to most of the questions i'll just do a
double check here in the chat
um
oh one more question that just came in
can we use um
rev is it reveal or real js slides on
pub
yes i i believe so um i think anything
published on cordo
can be published
i'll double check but i believe the
answer is yes
thank you and again we will gather all
these questions as well and group them
um
and also
at the same time we are doing that with
the welcome to cordo workshop questions
which there are a lot as well so maybe
isabella we can work together on some
blog posts to share all of those as well
absolutely thank you so much and thank
you everybody for joining in thank you
so much rachel
yeah yeah thank you so much really
really appreciate it and love to see all
the great questions here as well
thank you all so much for joining us
one last thing the recording will
be here immediately after the talk as
well so it's the same exact link on
youtube
if you're watching on linkedin i'll be
sure to just share that link with you
all there on linkedin right now
thank you all have a great rest of the
day take care bye everybody